foreign
[Applause]
fans it's me Louie here today in front
of the UHS hardware store checking out
this Acura TLX we're going to be
programming this vehicle to take a Brand
New Key adding a new key using the
top-down teen Ninja Pro we're making
sure that this new key works as it's
supposed to and it's going to be
programmed using this brand new program
that just came out earlier this year the
top Don 2 Ninja Pro is a fantastic new
programmer locksmiths love it we're
gonna check it out see how it does
programming new smart keys for this
Acura let's go together guys come on
first remove the wireless VCI from the
rear of the teen Ninja Pro and connect
it to the vehicle OBD port
[Music]
once connected select immo from the main
menu then press the VCI icon on the top
right to enter the VCI management
and sync the device for use
now choose your make
foreign
system Style
model
key type
ignition style
smart card type
and add smart key
next follow on-screen prompts to turn
the ignition on by pressing the start
stop button twice
then press ok
next remove all smart Keys New or Old
from the vehicle or programming will
fail
thank you
[Music]
press ok to continue once you have now
place the original smart key back into
the vehicle and press ok
[Music]
foreign
prompted place the key out of the
vehicle again and press ok
[Music]
place the new smart remote into the car
and press ok
[Music]
then wait for the vehicle communication
to accept the new key
[Music]
thank you
once prompted turn the car off and on as
requested until the immo security light
is no longer showing
[Music]
press OK if the security light goes out
as intended
then repeat the on off sequence until
successful programming is received
[Music]
when the key programming is complete
turn the car off and test your new
remote to make sure all buttons and
functions aren't working correctly
[Music]
be sure to remove your VCI After exiting
the system and ensure all your keys are
functioning and the ignition starts
normally before you finish up
foreign
[Music]
no challenge easily done by the top down
teen Ninja Pro quick easy to do works
just like a charm go ahead and check out
your top-down teen Ninja Pro right now
at uhs.harbor.com they're in stock and
ready to go for you right now as well as
keyless Factory Keys remotes smart Keys
everything from third party
accessibility easy to program for any
kind of video you're looking to program
for this look-alike easy to find really
affordable check it out right now
uhs.harbor.com search through them see
what you need check them out guys have a
good day enjoy this video and we hope to
see you guys real soon any other content
we have going on if you want to leave a
comment down below we'd love to hear
from you guys also make sure you like
this video And subscribe to our Channel
make sure you click the Bell icon so
that you know every time a new video is
coming out so we can get you guys aware
so you can check them out thank you guys
for coming along and being a part of
this journey we really enjoy having your
help and having you guys be part of this
whole content making process thank you
once again I'm Louie we'll see you guys
again real soon have a good one
thank you